this is a production of Cornell
University
but I'm gonna talk to you actually about
a weed that's kind of near and dear to
my heart which is is filled bindweed
you know it's a pretty cosmopolitan weed
throughout the world and in the United
States but we have a significant problem
up with it in California Central Valley
and so I'm gonna talk about the work
that I did there but we're gonna start
off talking about agriculture in the
Central Valley and and exactly why
bindweed has become such problem so if
you're not familiar with California's
Central Valley it extends everywhere
from sorry it extends everywhere from
about Kern County in the San Joaquin
Valley is made up of two - valleys and
up to the Delta region where where
Sacramento is going to be and then up
into the Sacramento Valley almost up to
Redding California if you're familiar
with it it is really the hub of
agricultural production now we do have a
lot obviously in the the Central Coast
and down in the Imperial Valley but
really the Central Valley is is dominant
with respect to the number of types of
crops that we can grow there's about
three hundred and three hundred and
sixty different agricultural products
and and that region is actually the sole
producer of at least 13 fruit vegetable
and nut commodities so all the almonds
that we're getting for your almond
lattes or whatever it's coming from
right in here that's that's the hub of
production it's a Mediterranean climate
which means it has dry summer so we're
very reliant on winter rains winter
snowfall in the Sierras and that
snowpack because all of the cropland
in the Central Valley is irrigated with
surface water allocations and
groundwater and this year has not been a
very good year for snow and rain in the
region and they actually just released
the 2020 surface water allocation
productions for agriculture in the state
and and frankly it's not good if you're
nor
the Delta you're expected to get about
50% of your contracted rate and if your
sells that Delta it's only 15 percent so
that shortcoming needs to be made up
with with groundwater and that's
actually going to become more and more
problematic because I'm going to show
you this next slide it's estimated about
200 million acre feet per year on
average is being withdrawn from the San
Joaquin Valley aquifer between 1986 and
2015 and we've got significant problems
with groundwater recharge so there's the
sustainable groundwater management act
which is now requiring the different
parts of the valley to reinvest water
resources into those aquifers and and
that's anticipating that about 500,000
the 700,000 acres are going to be a load
are going to need to be fallowed to be
able to make up this shortfall in in
water recharge so this is kind of
precipitated you know if water has
always been a concern in the Central
Valley
so shifts in the way the water has been
used a lot of the valley previously has
been flood irrigated there's now a
return to flood irrigation purposely for
this recharge potential but there has
been an increased use of drip irrigation
and many cropping systems in the region
mostly because of increased uniformity
of water application to the crop
relative water use reductions compared
to furrow or flood or sprinkler systems
and also protecting crop roots in San
Joaquin fields that have either very
shallow or saline water tables this has
also led to the adoption of more reduced
tillage in the Central Valley because a
berry drip tends to remain in place
multi season so that only permits
shallow soil working it helps reduce
labor and fuel usage and also lowers the
amount of dust that's generated anyone
who has spent any time in the Central
Valley El
cornea in the summer through the fall
the air quality can be quite a concern
because we have a lot of land working
that's going on whether we're preparing
beds for the coming cropping season or
shaking almonds and then sweeping
almonds up off the floor and anyone who
has seen California almond production
it's kind of like a scorched earth
policy like under those trees there is
there's no vegetation because we are
sweeping directly up off of the floor
and and and blowing dust is really
significant so there's air quality
issues it can trigger bronchitis and
asthma attacks and there's even the
potential the spores of the fungus that
cause Bali fever can become airborne
through you know extensive soil working
so there's there's a lot of impetus and
a lot of value in choosing to use reduce
tillage and drip irrigation systems and
the switch to say drip irrigation can
actually influence weed pressure in a
very positive way because we're reducing
the soil surface wedding and that's
reducing the amount of annual weed seed
germination an annual weed establishment
so these are a couple of studies that
were done in in the mid-2000s looking at
furrow versus drip irrigation and weed
pressure in processing tomatoes studies
and these red bars or furrow irrigated
systems and the gray bars or drip
irrigated systems and we can see that we
have reduce weed pressure that we need
to deal with because we don't have the
surface wedding that we used to have
which is very beneficial to the growers
fewer herbicide applications may be
needed fewer passes with with the
tractors that obviously generate the
dust and disturb soil but there's a big
but and there's a big caveat to this
system and that is field bind weed which
is a perennial vine field bind Reed has
as a root system that can extend ten to
thirty feet deep and it's really not
affected by soil moisture because of
this root network and it really
flourishes in our reduced tillage and
drip irrigation systems so this is a
picture I took of processing tomatoes in
Fresno County and 2018
this is actually at harvest or what
should have been harvest time this is a
massive field and and what this should
be is is a bunch of red tomatoes getting
ready for the harvest start to come
through but what this is is actually
filled bindweed and the grower actually
didn't even harvest because there was
nothing to harvest he just actually
burned this all down plowed it under and
said well we're gonna go in to Roundup
Ready pima cotton next year so I can
have the roundup the glyphosate as a
tool for managing the bind weed but this
is Roundup Ready pima cotton and and so
it does give us a tool it does give us a
strategy but but it's not perfect so we
have field bind weed that is problematic
not only in our horticultural systems
but as well as in our agronomic systems
as well it's also a problem in our young
orchards because we're tearing out a lot
of annual land and we're transitioning
to those high-value nuts right we're
going into almonds or going into
pistachios and we're going into annual
systems that had find weed problems and
now we're bringing that into our tree
and vine systems that you know although
fast growing you know don't develop that
shade level that we need to suppress
field bindweed for a number of years so
we also have limited tools available in
these systems for managing it field
bindweed was actually first reported in
virginia in 1739 and believed to have
come here as a possible seed contaminant
it was first reported formally via
herbarium records in San Diego County in
1850 and has since spread throughout the
remainder of the state and it's been
really frankly recognized as a problem
in the Central Valley since it got there
the most dreaded of perennial weeds the
most troublesome weeds of vineyard
orchard and other cultivated soils and
the most troublesome orchard and garden
we get naturalized in Canada or
California sorry so so it's been
problematic and again it's been
problematic almost since it got there so
just some basics about bindweed I'm
gonna just go over actually we've got
several different types of bindweed in
New York and I just gave this talk
yesterday of being able to tell field
bindweed from hedge bindweed from black
blind weeds we do have different
different species in the state of New
York I'm gonna focus on field buying
weed but just to give you a heads up
black bind weed fallopian fabulous
technically is not in the the bind weed
family that morning glory family it's
actually part of the not weed family and
this is why why common names can be a
problem because people are like I got
find weed I've got find weed I've got
find weed well which one do you have
because it really matters with how we
deal with it
so black bind weed is in the polygamy
she not weed family it's a summer annual
not a perennial like our hedge and field
bind weed but it can get some extensive
size to it it's got slender delicate
branches arrow shaped leaves
unlike the Morning Glory shape those
trumpet shaped flowers we have flowers
that develop on ray seems instead of in
just the axles and as being part of the
polygamy see it has an oak crea that is
really a giveaway for being able to
distinguish between it and and the
bindweed species which are in the conv V
Lacy and I use this for growers
yesterday so we can tell the difference
from between black bind weed and our
other species the oak rheya being a kind
of characteristic of the polygamy she so
the to true bind weeds that I think of
that are in the conv V lacy the morning
glory family are going to be filled bind
weed and hedge bind weed and it is
actually very important to know the
difference between these two species
because they don't necessarily react
similarly to management practices that
might be employed so just to go over so
we can tell are binding weeds apart and
I'm actually working on getting an
extension handout together to tell them
apart if we're thinking hedge bind weed
callous T Gia it's got larger leaves
this is the callous TT leaf with a
pointed tip and a much more deeply low
bass this is the life of Cambodia
services yield binary or rounded tip
much flatter bass callused idea produces
larger flowers and it actually has Brax
that cover the base of the floral tube
whereas the the Brax that are
characteristic of the fuel bindweed
flower are actually located about one
inch below the tube so this is just some
more pictures looking at the size and
shape differences this is the callused
EG leaf in the background
this is confabulate here when we look at
these pictures of the flowers and leaves
callous stevia is on the left and
volvulus is on the right there's
actually also differences in the stigma
the callused idea is just going to be a
ball where as it's hard to see in this
picture but maybe you can see from the
shadows the cambodia census is
thread-like so when we think about these
perennial vines they're really noted for
their root development and the
extensiveness of their root networks
within which what makes them so
problematic and so difficult to deal
with this is a picture provided by Andy
Santa sack down in Long Island where
he's got a weed garden edge bindweed
produces rhizomes and fibrous roots as
well as root buds and it also roots from
aerial shoots whereas field bindweed has
very deep vertical roots that extend
into the soil a network of lateral roots
and then again root buds that form new
crowns and tap roots the literature kind
of says that hedge bind weeds roots go
about ten feet deep and here you can see
that that rhizomatous Network but
whereas the the cap roots of field bind
we can bob ulis Adventists are known to
to to get about thirty feet deep and
I've been in some field sites in the
Central Valley of California with a
grower who's got his backhoe out because
he's doing some other work maybe with
the irrigation Network and we're just
back hoeing and just going and checking
and following those roots down to about
ten feet deep certainly at a minimum so
these these are some pictures again of
the field bindweed
system this is through the USDA Network
this is actually I think vagan in
actually has there was someone at Vagan
and university who was actually doing
extensive diagrams of a whole bunch of
different weed species and and crop
species root systems and this was
actually the drawing that they did of
him Bob Vila SAR fences field bindweed
again it's a deep and extensive root
system very deep lateral roots that
really occupy that top 1 to 2 feet of
soil and then those regenerative root
buds that support new crowns and tap
roots so we we think about these
perennial vines and when we think about
perennial species we think about the
root systems you know we think about
those rhizomes we think about that
underground network that supports their
establishment and persistence but I
don't want us to forget about the seeds
to field bindweed the reports say that
there can be about twenty thousand to
eight million seeds produced per acre
based on on the size of the population
the seeds become dormant about one month
after forming and and can remain in the
soil for decades can remain viable in
the soil for decades and this is the
field bindweed flowers and and these are
the seeds they're produced in a papery
capsule and they're about the size of
maybe barley grains very hard and shaped
like little kind of brown orange wedges
so there was some work looking at the
the mechanisms of dormancy in the conv v
lacey both callous t gia CPM and can bob
ulis Avensis both species have dormant
seed they're physically dormant and it's
physical damage to the seed which allows
water to enter and that facilitates
germination so this was a study they did
with non scarify seed 0 to about 15%
germination when Scarah fication takes
place you know getting a fairly high
germination rate based obviously
dependent on the quality of the seed
themselves so under field conditions
this kind of abrasion is going to occur
due to soil disturbance and freezing and
thawing cycles
but it's a Stormin see that also kind of
makes feel bindweed difficult to control
even if you were able to eliminate those
rhizomatous you know that that root
system it's it's difficult to be
controlled because you're not going to
be able to get rid of it easily through
using something like a stale seed bed
technique the Stormin C is really gonna
hinder you know the the consistent and
you know the concentrated emergence of
of these weeds you know it's gonna allow
for that that that seasonality you know
or that emergence throughout the season
because all seeds are gonna get scarify
dal ittle bit differently based on on
different disturbances movement in the
soil thickness of the seed coat whatnot
so one thing I'm interested in is we
always talk about our perennials well
you know what they all start off as
seedlings right they're all gonna start
off and kind of have this annual like
stage so how long does it take to go
from a seedling to a vine with root buds
that are capable of this kind of
perennial ization when does it start
taking on these characteristics of a
perennial plant because we talked about
it being easy to control as a seedling
well when does it stop being that easily
controlled seedling when when does it
start taking on these characteristics
where it's it's able to withstand
defoliation cultivation a glyphosate
application and what we found is it
actually doesn't take very long so again
this was a question I asked at what time
after seedling emergence if we go in and
to foliate a plant and we removed that
apical dominance do we have those root
buds that are forming that are
sufficiently formed and we have the
nutrient reserves that are gonna support
regrowth so this is some work that I
actually started with Ian Burke in in
Washington State University where we
were looking at blind weed growth and
development under different
environmental conditions different
temperatures and at about four weeks
after emergence and this is kind of
consistent with the literature that's
where we start to see those those root
buds forming that are going to form new
crowns and new tap roots and and this
was actually some work that was
published in 1982 as kind of
like a review of field bindweed and for
weed scientists in the crowd this was
actually a personal communication from
Jody hope out at UC Riverside that
basically she said that field blind
weeds were able to regrow from the roots
when above ground tissue was removed at
about three weeks after emergence there
was no data provided it was just
personal communication so I went in
starting last year and and looked at a
plant survival following defoliation so
basically what we did is we were growing
out buying weed seedlings and to
foliated them at either two weeks of age
four weeks of age six or eight weeks of
age and then looking at plant survival
and the number of vines that were
produced from from those root systems
and and basically we saw at about four
weeks after emergence about 25% of our
seedlings were were surviving and we're
we growing and we're regrowing from from
these these root buds that we could
unearth and then count and we're redoing
this study in the greenhouse here with a
couple of new york populations with the
washington population with california
populations and basically we're coming
up with exactly what we saw here exactly
what Jody reported at about three weeks
where we're starting to see survival so
we're doing this with physical
defoliation we're simulating a
cultivation event where we're looking at
different herbicides to see when
bindweed starts to be able to survive
those those different control events so
that brings us into managing behind
weeds so what are we using to manage
these these perennial vines and and
really frankly aren't our number one
tool there is a recent meta-analysis
that was was looking at field bind weed
management and and basically have like
the 484 different cases and datasets
that they looked at 80% of them looked
at herbicides and so we are using
herbicides heavily for the management of
field bind weed and really it comes down
to two classes of herbicides the ws sa 4
which is going to be arson
feda Coxon's to 4d dye Camba triclopyr
claw period and as well as ws SI 9 an
epsp s inhibitor and the the sole
chemical and in that group is glyphosate
which is known by the trade name roundup
so these are the post emergence
herbicides that we're using for field
bind weed management it is important to
understand and these tools aren't once
and done and and getting you know
complete control even with even with
what we would say are our best herbicide
tools this is going to require repeat
applications and I'm gonna argue it's
going to get us suppression rather than
control I kind of hate using the word I
use the word control with perennial
weeds but I kind of hate using the word
control because it really truly is
management or suppression now these and
tools aren't obviously once and done and
they they're of efficacy is very
variable for a number of reasons
one we find that perennial weeds respond
differently to these systemic herbicides
due to the time of the year that the
herbicides are applied and the
corresponding differences in herbicide
translocation glyphosate is a phloem
translocated herbicide so it's moving
with nutrient flow in the plant and and
so early in the year it's not going to
be as effective when we're starting to
push new growth as it might be later in
the season and perennial plants also
have extensive root systems and the
herbicides can be diluted in that tissue
and that can influence the efficacy so
this is just actually a paper that was
done in the 1980s looking at field bind
weed control with glyphosate and the
timing of applications and they had like
25 or 30 different trials in here and I
just summarized some of their responses
and they basically found that field bind
weed control with glyphosate was a
little bit better when you were in May
to August of the summer season when the
plant was flowering as opposed to when
it was in a more vegetative stage this
was all done in Kansas
so either April to May in the
early spring or August to November in
the fall when it was it was much more
vegetative rather than flowering and and
the reason for this was a function of
both the biology and the herbicide
activity one in in the spring we didn't
have that surface area available for
herbicide capture you've got a lot of
new growth coming up but you don't have
expansive tissue cover so you're really
not capturing a lot of herbicide that
you then need to be translocated back
down to the root system there's more
vigorous growth in in the flowering time
of year and and that's definitely we
know it's it maybe seems
counterintuitive but with with
herbicides like life you say we want we
want a happy plant we want a healthy
plant we want a vigorous plant it's
associated with the movement of
photosynthetic materials to meristems
including the the roots because it is a
phloem transported translocated
herbicide so this is kind of just my
theoretical bindweed curve where we see
much better control in the summer in the
spring we've got the insufficient
biomass capture these herbicides the
emerging shoots mean that we've got flow
and movement away from the roots and the
roots are where we want to get a
herbicide like life you say in the fall
we have natural senescence that's
occurring with the leaves we have pest
infestations we have disease problems
that reduce the vigor and the biomass
that's available for herbicide capture
we also have changes in bud dormancy
going from a primary dormancy to a
secondary dormancy in the fall that I
also think are affecting glyphosate
efficacy this is just what I'm going to
bring up about understanding glyphosate
translocation under different
environmental conditions and in response
to plant size and root system size
really how far is this herbicide moving
and how long does it take to get where
it needs to go so this is actually one
of my cotton trials here's where the the
boom cut off where we put the glyphosate
so here's the plants that are showing
glyphosate injury and right here is
bindweed looking fairly on
and actually this is this is even closer
this was done in a pistachio orchard
where we were applying glyphosate on on
the bed shoulders so this is about maybe
four inches apart here's where the
glyphosate came into contact with the
field bindweed here's where the
glyphosate didn't so are are these roots
connected are these plants attached
maybe maybe they're not but but we see
this pretty consistently that you know
maybe where we have this kind of
extensive plant development maybe we're
not getting maybe we're just not simply
able to capture enough herbicide and
just not get enough movement into these
root systems because of the nature of
the root system and this is something
definitely wanting to look at looking at
plant size looking at root system size
and then looking at the nature of
symptom expression with this product so
I'm going to bring I'm gonna bring this
up because this is going to feed into
the next slide where we talk about
differences in herbicide efficacy and
why it's important to know say the
difference between hedge and fuel
bindweed
so we don't have a lot of post emergence
herbicides in tomatoes that we can use
for the management of any weed species
much less field bindweed the two that we
do have matrix which is rim sulfur on an
ALS inhibitor and shark which is
carpentras own a PPO inhibitor shark
basically just burns tissue off so it's
just a contact herbicide it burns
everything down and a matrix is a
systemic applied herbicide and in my
work in California I see a burn down you
know with shark eventually you know I
start to see regrowth of the field
bindweed but with matrix I don't see any
real efficacy matrix applied post at all
and this is actually really interesting
is because Brian Brown from New York
State IPM and Hans Walter Peterson where
were talking to me when I was still out
in California and they're like you know
we're getting really good control a bind
we with matrix
why aren't you you know and I'm like why
are you you know I'm not getting
good control well here's the reason they
were actually spraying hedge bindweed
and and this is why it's important to
know the differences between your
species so they were working in grapes
and they found if they sprayed rim
sulfur on to X or glyphosate 3x they
were getting about a hundred percent
suppression in hedge find weed as soon
as they said oh gosh we're in hedge
bindweed what does it do in field
bindweed
the the you know the results changed
they were able to get the suppression of
field mind reading grapes but they
weren't able to together to replicate
those same results in field bindweed
so I'm just I'm throwing this in there
because this is also some work hoping to
do with both of them here in New York is
really understanding some of the
differences between hedge and field
bindweed in their response to different
management strategies so that's really
what we're talking about when I talk
about post emergence herbicides and now
I kind of switched to pries and and it's
like why why why please we're talking
about perennial species you know our
priests pre-emergent soil applied
herbicides going to be actually
effective against perennial plants and
not not just the seedling stage is there
any activity against those perennial
vines and actually yes there is and
we're gonna talk about that so why
should we be even thinking about
pre-emergence herbicides soil applied
herbicides for suppressing field
bindweed
in in a cropping system and and it's
because we frankly in in California
where I've done all my research is you
know we're obviously not suppressing it
outside of the crop you know we're not
effectively managing it you know in our
fallow systems to date so you know we
can't afford to necessarily take this
land out of production you know there's
a lot of growers are like you know what
I would love to fallow but I can't I
have to plant I have to grow so so we
need to find a tool that's able to
suppress field bind weed in the crop
even if it gets us a couple of weeks
that gets our seedlings up that gets our
transplants established out of a
transplant shock and gets their canopy
developing so that we can just gain an
edge on this plant that has become so
pervasive in our crop production systems
so this is just a summary of some work
that I did with field bindweed
in a tomato production systems between
2013 to 2015 these are the results from
individual trials just grouped by
herbicide rate and category and then
this is kind of just the overall summary
and that we we do find that we do have
herbicides pre-emergent soil applied
herbicides that have activity on those
perennial vines that can actually
suppress the growth and development of
those that new growth and basically in
our tomato production system we found
it's treflan which is a dye nitro
aniline has suppressive activity
matrix-matrix which doesn't have
activity post does have activity pre
it's an ALS inhibitor and then zeus
which goes the active ingredient is
offenders own it's a PPO inhibitor which
is actually we have for youth or
nutsedge control in in processing
tomatoes in california actually has some
pretty good activity against fuel
bindweed now it has pretty good activity
against the tomatoes too it's it's a hot
herbicide and it will cause some damage
but it is an effective strategy this is
just what part of the results from a
study that my eye colleague Brad Hanson
and I put in looking at trifler illan
alone or in combination with rim solar
on insult centrosome following a tomato
transplanting and finding that you know
what we could get about four weeks of
suppression you know to help us get our
tomatoes established before we really
needed to actively compete with field
bindweed
these are just some guidelines again try
Fluellen which is a pre plan
incorporated herbicide gives us
some activity matrix rim soldier on
gives us pre-emergence activity it has
post Merchants activity against a bunch
of other weed species but not field
bindweed
in my experience and then self-interest
own which we had a lot of growers using
where we needed to suppress Knights edge
and our transplanted tomatoes actually
has activity dole Magnum has actually no
effect on the perennial vines and and we
put it in there for for other reasons to
catch other grasses or maybe even for
nutsedge suppression now in in
california treflan is a great tool if
we're in furrow irrigated systems though
however the wedding and the drying can
actually cause soil cracks and it will
allow the bindweed basically to emerge
up through the cracks in that soil and
and frankly just miss our treated zones
so we do have the activity but again in
our furrow irrigated systems it can be
bypassed we talked about processing
tomatoes field blind weed is problematic
in our cotton in the San Joaquin Valley
if we were in rotation with with
processing tomatoes which by the way if
we're in rotation with processing
tomatoes that takes product like matrix
out of out of the mix it takes offense
razón out of the mix which leaves us
with trifler illan as a product to
potentially use because of plant back
restrictions and potential injury to the
cotton crop so this is actually cotton
right here is a patch of fuel bindweed
you can see a patch here and here here's
here's the cotton seedling hot and is
super slow to get up out of the ground I
mean it's it's slow it grows slowly it
emerges slowly and and this is the field
bind weed so what we're doing is we're
relying super heavily on just repeat
applications of glyphosate which might
not be the best time because again all
of this root reserves
you know we're pushing nutrients up to
support new growth in the spring but
we've gotten really not much else that
work so we're putting a lot of roundup
down trying to suppress this field
behind weed you know to release these
seedlings and let the cotton get up
another reason that we want to actually
manage fuel
I read in cotton is steel bindweed can
actually support white fly and and white
fly are actually one of the contributors
to a problem that we is called sticky
cotton so Athens and and white flies
produce a lot of sugary residues that
gets on the cotton trying to put that
through a gin and then trying to put
that sticky cotton through a mill that's
a way that's gonna get you banned very
very very very quickly Millers have no
tolerance for sticky cotton I've heard
stories in in Arizona of send in sticky
cotton and yeah you know they're not
taking you again so making sure being
able to - if manage an alternate host
for for white flies is important so
these are the cotton herbicides that
that we're using this is from the
California Department of pesticide
resources were using a lot of glyphosate
obviously you know just like anywhere
else in the country where we have
Roundup Ready crop systems you know we
adopted glyphosate heavily these are
these are our next closest herbicides ox
a floor fan pendimethalin fluminox is in
and then paraquat and frankly the
paraquat there is a boolean I'm not even
sure it's actually there as a herbicide
or else it's as a pre plant burned down
as is the flu my oxygen so we're using a
lot of glyphosate and we've already said
you know you know we're putting a lot of
glyphosate down are we getting as good
of control as we need to get early
season in the cotton we are using
pendimethalin which is in the same
family chemical family as life estate
but is it working as effectively at
suppressing field bindweed so again I'm
not convinced that the glyphosate
applications in cotton in the absence of
other tools are frankly enough I mean we
do we just can't say that we're gonna
well we're gonna control field bindweed
by planting Roundup Ready cotton that
Roundup Ready I am not sure is is
actually sufficient this is again a
cotton field and you can see the patches
of field bindweed and you can see here
the the quintessential glyphosate
on that on that field bindweed it gets
up faster than the cotton and the timing
the glyphosate applications aren't ideal
biologically so so that's why I said
okay you know we have to be thinking
about pre-emergent herbicides again
we're using a lot of pendimethalin we
have a glyphosate resistant grass jungle
rice so we are using pendimethalin where
we've got that those problems to try and
manage that pre-emergence but we do to
have trifler illan open to us we have
plant back restrictions and and
pre-harvest intervals that we need to be
thinking about that might kind of limit
trifler lens use but frankly it's it's
probably our best pre-emergent tool
right now in cotton that we have even
though pendimethalin and trifler illan
are in the same chemical family and they
perform similarly on many annuals not
all but many annuals they definitely
differ with bind weed control or bind
weed suppression both seedlings and
vines this was a study I did with a
basically our farm manager down at the
Westside Research Center in Five Points
California in each of the pictures we've
got two three four and five weeks after
treatment the leftmost picture is
treflan this is prale h2o pendimethalin
and then our untreated check and frankly
even though prowl and and treflan are in
are in the same chemical family they
don't perform similarly we get better
suppression using treflan as opposed to
prowl so we put in a trial to look at
can we use treflan in cotton you know to
suppress our our our field bind weed
problems and we put truffula and down
ppi in pima cotton we had other post
emergence herbicide applications stacked
on top of this but i'm just gonna pull
out basically the treflan versus the
untreated check we put these in on about
May 24th and about July 8th yeah we were
seeing about 50% suppression or a little
bit more than 50% suppression with our
treflan averaged over all
our our herbicide combinations now when
we put a roundup most emergency roundup
applications and alternating cultivation
events on that we do spectacular and
we're able to suppress field bindweed so
much so that we can get an extra foot or
so in size of in cotton height by
suppressing the weed if you're
interested in perennial production
systems we again we have it in our tree
and vines so we looked at some of our
more commonly used herbicides these
Ruderman applications that were made in
november and then looking at field bind
weed emergence in the season and
suppression in april alley on whether at
three and a half or five ounces per acre
or pindar GT no effect on the field bind
weed over time
here's matrix again and here's deuce
again that we saw in in our our tomato
systems and and Brian Brown actually did
some working grapes here in New York and
found that feel bind we could be
suppressed in the spring with a fall
application of case our on the active
ingredient is doc lobe Anil and it's in
the ws sa three group just like trifler
Alanis so this is another WS sa three
showing suppressive activity against
field bindweed perennial vines now we
talked about alley on not being able to
suppress field bind read but it will
suppress grapevines so alley on is
actually registered for using grapevines
but only when they're greater than five
years of age so here is a perennial vine
that alion will just destroy if it's
applied on sandy soils and at the wrong
time this is ally on injury but it
doesn't it doesn't suppress field so so
just just so I like to I like to show
this I'm going to be showing this to two
great growers at Bev New York tomorrow
you know the the kinds of you know
having to be very thoughtful about the
herbicides that we use so I want to talk
about soil disturbance because you know
this is when we're not using herbicides
this is the next
most common strategy for managing sealed
bindweed
and basically all of our information
goes back to work that was done in
Kansas in the 1940s and we don't have
much much evidence to suggest that that
we've come upon any improvement since
then or except for maybe alternating
glyphosate and and cultivation events
but basically they found that if you
wanted to eradicate field bindweed
using a cultivation you needed to
cultivate every two to three weeks for
basically two to almost three seasons to
basically suppress or what they said
eradicate four you'll bind weed and I'm
gonna say it's probably not eradication
because I'm gonna bet there's a lot of
seed in there and we know the seed can
persist for decades in the soil they
found deeper cultivations were simply
more expensive and soil quality
degradation with time so cultivation if
you're gonna do it it's got to be
frequent because we've actually found
that soil disturbance infrequent soil
disturbance actually makes populations
worse because all you do is you spread
root fragments both within and between
fields and we did this actually on the
UC Davis campus we had a farm manager
who would only cultivate once per summer
his fallow fields and took a small patch
that was about the size of this room and
made it about ten acres at the end of
three years so a lot of work that's been
done looking at burial depth and
desiccation time you've got to bury
fragments root fragments deeper than
about 10 inches to reduce respraying
potential from those fragments if you're
gonna try to desiccate them by bringing
them up and letting them dry out you're
gonna need about 48 to 96 hours to
prevent reefs Prouty
this is another study again 12 to 14
inches to suppress rerouting and the
larger your fragments are the more
likely they are to reefs Prout and this
brings me to this slide obviously again
bury the rhizomes more deeply to prevent
reefs prowling and regrowing but they
actually cut rhizomes up to different
sizes for field bindweed and basically
found about anything an inch or larger
has the ability
to reroute and regrow maybe not as
frequently and the one-inch fragment as
frequently as a five inch fragment but
small pieces can regenerate and this is
why infrequent cultivation is really
very very very problematic and makes the
situation worse so a lot of growers we
are in the process like I said of
potentially needing to fallow and so a
lot of growers are looking at fallow
ground management and I think maybe a
little too late in California we should
be thinking about this a lot longer so
this is a this was on the the research
farm this is where we went in and put
roundup on on 7:27 and then et which is
a defoliant that we're using cotton on
eight seven and basically we saw vines
reemerge about nine one now understand
this has been fallow land that hasn't
seen any irrigation since the previous
March and so we went in with glyphosate
just burned it back and we still got
vines reemerging on the 1st of September
this was roundup on 727 with shark on 87
took Allah binds a little bit longer to
to reimburse it was 927 and this was
probably our most uh most physically
destructive we put roundup down on 727
we went in and basically we took a we
took a basically giant blades in at
about 15 to 18 inches deep and we just
ripped the soil we just ripped it right
through and severed the top growth from
those deep deep deep fragments and then
disc the surface twice and as of the
31st of October there was no emergence
of field bindweed and we've got actually
a lot of growers in California this is
what they're doing now I heard reports
from my colleagues out there a lot of
growers are taking shanks and knives in
and just ripping as deep as they can go
to manage their field bindweed so my
thoughts site selection and effective
pre plant and in crop herbicide use are
going to be critical starting clean and
staying clean mechanical disturbance is
going
be important but it needs to be applied
frequently and actually I was talking
with Emily Reese from Claire family
farms and they had a bindweed problem
and they went and that that's what they
did last summer one of their fields
every two weeks they went in and
cultivated they just took it out of
production their organic farm out of
production out of production and
cultivate motivate cultivate cultivate
to to try and you know basically
exhausted nutrient reserves physical
suppression via mulches and cover crops
I was just talking with an organic
grower yesterday at the eastern New York
fruit veg meeting about going in and
doing some tarping work with them to
look at physical suppression of field
bindweed coupled with strategic
cultivation and flaming events field
bindweed can be sensitive to shading so
basically how do we keep it suppressed
in the crop until we can get prop
canopies to establish selecting
cultivars for canopy developing reducing
transplant shock to get this canopies
developing faster and improving crop
establishment not trying to reinvent the
wheel but frankly we need to know a
little bit more about the phenology and
the growth and development of these
species so better target control
opportunities because this is what I
think we need to be doing we need to be
thinking about how we're gonna disrupt
dormancy an initiating rude but bud
Dorman germination when this plant
really wants to senesce and utilize the
weather and the environment for the
control so again understanding Bud
dormancy I think this is this is we need
we need more information because this is
going to help us get a leg up so this
was the theoretical bindweed curve that
I brought up before and this is what I'm
thinking about now how do we change this
curve from the red bar to the to the
blue one how do we extend our control
potential and and raise it up but I you
know one thing I'm really interested in
is how is climate change can affect this
curve how is rising temperatures in co2
can affect biomass accumulation and
control efficacy are we gonna have a
longer growing season and does that mean
more opportunities for control or more
chances for escape and recovery
uh just throwing this up here this is my
2020 research program that I'll be doing
there is there is bindweed in here going
to be doing some perennial we control
trials and apples and grapes
obviously I'm a specialty crop weed
scientist so focusing on the vegetable
systems whether it's it's herbicide
efficacy herbicide safety dicamba
240 drift and volatility injury to our
vegetable systems organic herbicide
performance time of day effects with
herbicide efficacy what we're finding to
be important particularly for our
herbicide resistant weeds as well as
taking on a statewide herbicide
resistant screening project and this is
my contact information and if you're on
Twitter or if you're on Instagram I have
a pretty active extension that you can
tap into and I do a lot of weed ID on on
my Instagram feed so students I do a lot
of weed idea on my Instagram feed it
could be a resource so thank you very
much this is the that's the question and
I think that yes that this is a case
like we tell everyone's like well treat
your perennials in the fall treat them
in the fall it's going down well when
when when does that fall when do this
when does that dormancy tick in you know
and when do we not have that
translocation to where we need it to go
and I think with with one perennial weed
and I can't remember the species and I'm
hope I'm not miss remembering it that
they actually found that some of those
meristems that you know the the vascular
tissue isn't completely formed so you
couldn't even move that that that
herbicide there effectively do we have a
situation like that with your bind weed
I don't think we know enough about the
bud
armen see when it's going dormant you
know what what what it looks like
morphologically and and what our
movement is and i I think you know I
think it's I only say being disingenuous
by saying go out and treat in the fall
because like I think we need a better
idea of when does it's you know what is
our efficacy curve and and when when you
know what what don't we know about
morphology and physiology and biology
with the species that's why I said I
don't want to reinvent the wheel but
we've got and now because we don't have
the option so it well we think that what
we're doing is we're severing that top
root system from the deeper root system
that's supporting the that that's tapped
into the deeper water because this has
received no irrigation no rainfall for
about five five months and so it's it's
just we're trying to eliminate that yet
that connection and then going in
putting that glyphosate on and then
going in and basically fragmenting that
that root system up I've heard of people
who might be doing something a little
illegal of putting then treflan down and
some really like concentrated layers in
addition to that and I don't know I mean
yeah technically it probably could maybe
suppress that regrowth of buds the buds
tend to be much more surface surface or
oriented that your the number of buds
that you have for regrowth decreases
with depth but that's that's our
hypothesis is we're just cutting it off
from its water source so we know that we
have differential sensitivity
among populations there's been papers
published there was a paper that was
recently published and I don't know if I
haven't read it carefully enough and I
haven't talked to a colleague who
focuses on the genetics of the comb
vaudeville ACA I want to discuss this
with her but they actually believe that
they found or they suggested that they
had increased epsps copy number and what
they suspected was a resistant field
bindweed
now they the problem was I'm not sure
that they they're what they were
comparing it to wasn't in the same it
wasn't the same species so I think we
need to be a little thoughtful about
that but they were suggesting there are
resistance mechanisms in the field
bindweed it came out last year like I
said I want to either I do want to talk
to a colleague about exploring this
further because I think that could
probably be a good a free grant getting
populations from around the country
looking at the differences and if we do
have this increased copy number which is
a mechanism for resistance and that's
actually you know pretty that's that's
pretty significant so so there are
differences I'm not sure that we've
completely identified why yet you know
it was there was work that was done and
then it it just hasn't been followed
through and we saw this recent paper and
I think it needs much more consideration
yeah that's yeah well you know there I'm
gonna tell you what yeah so we are like
all over the place I think with with
with soils in California you know if
you're if you're talking to Jeff
Mitchell we're like you know cover
cropping and and you know we've got to
do that and there's others like what if
we don't get the winter rain and you
know we need to be able to to form the
beds and and yeah so I it is definitely
something I've wondered and I've
considered I'm not the soils person so
you know I think you know I've been a
little too hyper focused on I just got
to get rid of behind me first but I
think there's there's definite concerns
there
you know and and you know our following
is only gonna get worse obviously with
with Sigma our foul like they're
following I'm here now they're following
is only only gonna become more extreme
and you know what I think there's that's
gonna actually be problematic because we
are gonna build up a lot of weeds in
those fallow systems I think bindweed
is one of those species that's going to
run rampant of Russian thistle is gonna
be all over that
not a perennial but problematic in its
own right so that Russian thistle is
going to get there and and and those
those weeds are gonna have consequences
for four neighboring crops and any crops
that eventually do come in so yeah
there's there's definitely a soil health
there but like I said pretty much we
were these are fields that we couldn't
we couldn't use we couldn't even plant
into on the west side you know no no no
one I'm like no researchers gonna put
their tomatoes in this because it's you
know it's it's it's it's a battle even
even and like are sensitive cotton
trials and we just it was a battle so
these fields were effectively out of
production this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu